welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of HBO's
The Last of Us episode one when you're
lost in the darkness based on the
naughty dog games written by Neil
druckman and co-created by druckman and
Chernobyl writer Craig Mason this series
hits the heartbreaking survivalist
horror notes from my favorite arcs of
The Walking Dead I'm just loving this
show so let's break it down scene by
scene for all the visual details that
you might have missed all the little
choices that make the show so good also
break room hosts Brandon Jessica and
Anna cover the differences from the
games in their after show give that a
watch along with Anna's full explanation
of everything you need to know going
into this series and a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive launching February 17th in which
every week I will be digging even deeper
into select titles like everything
everywhere all at once with a more
investigatory Focus while I continue to
break down Easter eggs here on new
rockstars okay this Premiere episode
opens with a prologue that's actually
not in the games a 1968 talk show
discussing Global pandemics and that's
your biggest worry yes any kind of virus
but most probably something similar to
influenza because of air travel through
the year
I meant people on planes that was
something you described in your book now
in history this would have been one of
the earliest broadcasts about
epidemiology a topic that we are all now
familiar with having lived through covid
but by setting this opening scene in the
1960s this series sets our Notions of
pandemics has been Antiquated and
instead presents an alternate history in
which things could have played out very
differently one hypothetical forgotten
because viruses are really what we fear
from here forward not fungi also Ellie
later deduces that the 60s songs on the
radio are Joel's Smuggler code with Bill
and Frank meaning nothing new so this
might be the show's way of saying this
is really nothing new we have known
about all these natural threats for
decades this opening TV broadcast also
evokes the TV broadcast that opened I Am
Legend with Emma Thompson as a doctor in
the past proclaiming the cure for cancer
which led to that present-day viral
outbreak the host of this TV show is
played by Josh printer big head from
Silicon Valley and the fungusphere Dr
Newman is played by Josh Hannah who
played the brother in The Mummy films
and a number of other great roles he
talks about a fungus that affects the
mind of an ant theorizing that such fun
I could evolve to infect humans due to
Rising global temperatures one Gene
mutates and an ascomycetia candida ergot
cordyceps aspergillus any one of them
could become capable of borrowing into
our brains and taking control not of
millions of us but billions of us the
camera cuts to Newman right on cordyceps
because that is the name of the real
world and infecting fungus that Neil
druckman based the fungus of The Last of
Us games on and it is the fungus of this
story he goes on to warn billions of
puppets with poisoned Minds permanently
fixed on one unifying goal to spread the
infection to every last human alive by
any means necessary so if that happens
we lose and during all this the camera
shows the studio audience who look fully
non-plussed and unafraid dull-eyed
puppets just ready for the taken now the
awesome looking opening title animation
mirrors the fungal spread that's set to
haunting acoustic notes strum died
composer Gustavo Santo alala just like
the animation that opens the games
Gustavo also composed the great music in
the games and here he works with David
Fleming but this spreading of the
cordyceps fungus reminds us of other HBO
openings like Game of Thrones or House
of the Dragon like it's spreading across
a world map Rising its own fungal City
structures that supplant our human
civilization eventually the fungus
actually takes the shape of a map of the
continental United States and it's
subtle but you can actually see Tiny
spores floating from stock to Stock and
Two of the stocks take the shape of a
taller person and a shorter person
representing Joel and Ellie the focal
characters of this story now The Last of
Us is really one of the better versions
of the whole Lone Wolf and Cub
relationship which of course Pedro
Pascal also played really well in the
Mandalorian now the first half of this
pilot episode follows Joel's daughter
Sarah in 2003 Austin Texas the way part
one of the game's prologue follows Sarah
but we spent a lot more time with Sarah
on the show which is the show's way of
saying just because we get to know
characters for extended sequences
doesn't mean this show is not going to
kill them off this is survivalist horror
it's called The Last of Us oh and by the
way if you have not played the games and
you don't want to get spoiled about what
happens I'm Gonna Save My speculation
for details that might set up currently
unestablished plot points known from the
games or from the comics in this segment
at the end so if you don't know anything
about what happens in the future of this
story don't worry I'm not gonna spoil
anything in these breakdowns now the
open window blows a gentle breeze to
wake up Sarah and there are some tiny
particles floating over her nose but to
be clear Neil druckman did clarify that
they decided that instead of spreading
via Airborne spores this fungus is going
to spread via these creepy oral tendrils
this is actually inspired by concept art
from the game in the game Sarah reads a
newspaper where it suggested that the
fungus came from crops imported from
South America but here the radio
newscaster mentions disturbances and
Jakarta and riots and warnings for all
Americans to get out of there suggesting
that the origin in the show might be
from Indonesia or somewhere else in
Southeast Asia one of the countries
bordering the Indian Ocean now thank you
to betterhelp for sponsoring this video
you remember that moment in game where
Cap Saul alone facing off against Thanos
then everybody shows up to help there is
a reason we all cheered so hard when
that happened someone we love got help
and it was such a relief getting help is
good and now thanks to better help
getting help is easy too better help is
the world's largest therapy service and
it's 100 online with better help you can
tap into a network of over 25 000
licensed and experienced therapists who
can help me with a wide range of issues
to get started just answer a few
questions about what you need and what
your preferences are for therapy that
way better help can match you to the
right therapist from their Network once
that is done you can talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message a therapist
at any time and schedule live sessions
when it's convenient for you if your
therapist isn't the right fit for any
reason you can switch to a new therapist
at no additional charge better help lets
you get the same professionalism and
quality you expect from in office
therapy but with a therapist who is
custom picked for you with more
scheduling flexibility and at a more
affordable price to get 10 off your
first month you can scan the QR code or
click the link in the description or
just go to betterhelp.com new rockstars
that's better
h-e-l-p.com Slash new rockstars for 10
off your first month of therapy but
throughout the first episode of this
episode the story beats are very similar
Sarah is celebrating Joel's birthday and
fixing this watch as a gift Joel
fretting over a Contracting job notice
how Joel slaps his wrist after
accidentally checking it for the time a
little not that he misses having a watch
that works properly something Sarah has
likely noticed also in the background of
this living room of this house is Joel's
guitar Joel's play another guitar is
something that becomes very important
later on in the games and probably of
the show now a lot of the dialogue is
taken directly from the game like Sarah
later joking that she sold drugs to pay
for the watch Joel pretending that the
watch didn't work so I'm not going to
point out every time a line or something
is from the game exactly but Sarah's
shirt is interesting to point out this
is the same pink Helicon drop shirt but
instead of the 2010 tour it's now the 2
2 tour because in the games it takes
place in 2013 in this show the flashback
takes place in 2003. also really cool
detail in the game most of the tour
stops on that shirt are locations you
later visit in the game Boston
Pittsburgh Jackson Salt Lake City Etc
all the details are very 2003 though
like a destiny shout Survivor poster on
Sarah's wall she's got a band tour shirt
with 2002 on it there's Dido's white
flag on the radio and in the classroom a
president a good old George Bibby Bush
who before becoming president was
governor of the great state of Texas so
they might have already had his photo on
their wall and in the classroom Sarah
gets distracted by this glare
picking up heads I swear you will use
this later in life believe me
Okay so
kids wrist is twitching muscle spasms
being an early symptom of infection also
a subtle cough before the Bell Rings
there I love how they build attention
because they know that we watching this
are now a little triggered by hearing
coughs this episode is titled when
you're lost in the darkness which is the
first part of the fireflies Mantra that
Mantra ends with look for the light here
Sarah gets distracted from the light by
what a cough in the repair shop the
phone rings the beginning of the scene
in the background and then a moment
later that Lebanese co-owner closes
early rushes there out of there
suggesting that that call was from
family in the Middle East alerting her
to how bad things are getting and then
in her neighbor's house behind Sarah
Nana contorts inner mouth opens why does
that fungus infection takes hold of her
body but she stays out of focus so we
can't really tell what's happening which
makes it even creepier it reminds me a
lot of that scene in it chapter 2 when
Pennywise takes the form of the old
woman creeping in the background behind
Bev now Nana also refuses to eat in this
scene I remember earlier she refused to
eat those biscuits which director Craig
Mason hinted might be some breadcrumbs
here that are going to come back later
like there might be another symptom to
the fungal infection being loss of
appetite because the fungus is really
eating your flesh from the inside it
doesn't need other food Sarah borrows
the DVD Curtis and Viper 2 which is a
reference to the games Joel's favorite
80s action movie that gets referenced
what movie you guys gonna watch what's
Joel into
uh Curtis and Viper two that's the one
that's been on my radar for a while now
later that night when Sarah enters the
house which by the way why would you do
this notice how the wheelchair on the
far right is empty just a little
concerning sign that that fungus is now
puppeting Nana's motor functions it's
just unsettling to realize that this
fungus in a way fixes our physical
ailments to make us more mobile now Brad
Leland is actually buddy Garrett even
Friday Night Lights love seeing him show
up here and he does such a great job
acting this moment
now what we think is his paralyzing fear
and his wide eyes is actually the fungus
taking over because later when we see
him in the street he attacks someone
else he too is infected here now the
tendrils that snake out of Nana's mouth
are even more sickening in my opinion
than the spores of the game but a little
physical detail here I love how
dim's womb as Nana raises her head so
the first time we see a bite happen it's
not a cannibalistic zombie bite she's
not trying to Feast on her brains it's a
parasite transferring from one host
burrowing into the bloodstream of a new
host now this truck sequence is awesome
it plays out similarly to the game we
see the burning Farmhouse the way they
pass a family leaving them behind all
the highways blocked off but Craig Mason
shoots this in these amazing long takes
there's a 50 second shot from just
inside the truck in which they must have
perfectly timed and choreographed people
running down the street lit by the
truck's headlights the fact that we stay
in the chaos of the truck reminds us a
lot of the amazing chaotic car long take
of Children of Men I like how it's a
movie screening of Midnight Madness
erupting into the street and then as the
truck backs up the entire time in the
sky I didn't notice this the first time
I looked at it you can totally see the
747 losing control up above their heads
but we don't really notice what's
happening until too late because of all
the chaos that's happening around us
actually it's that plane's front wheel
that breaks off and ricochets off the
building and wrecks their truck
afterward Tommy gets separated as Joel
and Sarah are pinned on where's that
Pioneer Way Joel will become a bit of a
Westward moving Pioneer on this series
but as in the game they are stopped by a
soldier who gets the order to kill them
and Joel who either he or his brother
Tommy were a Desert Storm veteran knows
what it looks like when a soldier gets a
message to kill the soldier fires on
them hitting Sarah and Tommy kills off
the soldier before you kill Joel Sarah
bleeds out and dies but there is
something interesting that happens here
we don't actually see the exact moment
Sarah dies the camera swings over to
Tommy whose voice cracks as he says his
brother's name and then when we swing
back to Sarah her eyes are lifeless so
then we jump to 20 years later in the
Boston quarantine Zone following another
kid that we don't stay with for too long
they wheel him in and they give him
ephedra patch to hold so Pedra is the
federal Disaster Response agency a
fema-like agency from the game it
becomes the country's governing military
Authority now this kid sees a poster
explaining how long the infection takes
based on where the wound is on the body
the leg being the longest which is where
this kid's wound is we don't even know
if this kid can read like he clearly
doesn't understand what's going on and
it's especially cruel how this Soldier
hides her expression after he tests
positive
what if I told you that after we gave
you some medicine we're gonna find you
your favorite food to eat and later this
poor kid is identified by his bright
green shoelaces which I think is a nod
to Schindler's List when that girl in
the red coat is later identified on a
pile of corpses that's being carted over
to be burned and notice how despite
shoelaces being a hot commodity in the
qz they do not scavenge this boy's
shoelaces either out of respect or maybe
out of caution now in the game the
infection testing process is actually
revealed by an adult man testing
positive in the qz and he gets shot
right there but this more emotionally
brutal death was added to get
parallelism between Joel cradling Sarah
and now Joel is numb as he cradles this
dead boy this actually was the original
ending of this episode before HBO
suggested taking more time to build out
the present day and most importantly to
introduce Joel to Ellie Joel takes the
worst jobs like this one and Sewer
maintenance perhaps to her maintenance
to learn what the best smuggling routes
are but really also to just get the most
valuable ration card so that he can
bribe the soldiers he passes some wanted
posters offering a reward for Marlene
posters like these appear in the qz in
the game we see some amputees wearing
Desert Storm shirts and a guy in a Gore
Lieberman shirt for the Democratic
candidates in the 2000 election now Gore
and Joe Lieberman all of their fashion
technology froze in the early 2000s when
everything fell apart we also see some
guys assigning to paint over some
graffiti left by the fireflies that's
her sigil and we know that they are
recruiting from throughout the qz the
amputees we see might be a world detail
of people having cut off wounded limbs
to prevent infection in the game it's
not totally clear if amputation works
like that in the Left Behind game Ellis
had his arm amputated but we never
really find out for sure if it worked
because they ended up bleeding out
before they could find out three
trespassers are hung in North Square you
can see signs for North Square in real
life Boston this is the historic area
well the whole city is a historic area
but this is a special area where Paul
Revere's house is these kinds of
executions by British soldiers were part
of what agitated American Store Bolton
reveres Time Joel meets up with his one
soldier and we see this soldier's hand
twitching showing how bad he's jonesing
for these pills but also how he will
have a very itchy trigger finger later
Joel knows how bad this Soldier is
addicted or I could just shoot you yeah
but then what would you do
the bag back be
CK be something in limited
Limited in the game Joel is a Smuggler
who's always holding on to odds and ends
that he can Workshop into useful tools
Tess chats with Robert whose guys jumped
her about a car battery that she paid
for and he's sold to someone else a car
battery that we later learned didn't
even work now in the game it's actually
a cache of guns that Robert scammed from
Joel and Tess but this show seems to
establish Joel and Tess is a bit less
bloodthirsty and also wants to establish
a stronger bond between Joel and his
brother Tommy and Joel having to travel
Westward to find Tommy before he ever
meets Ellie ultimately this introduces
Joel as at first a more peaceful
protective figure which Petro Pascal is
so good at as didn't Jaron on the
Mandalorian we mean Ellie who initially
goes under the Alias of Veronica played
by Bella Ramsey Lena Mormont from Game
of Thrones the fireflies have chained
her up and they test her cognitive motor
functions why are they doing this well
we later learned that she has been
infected and they're trying to prove
that the infection didn't really affect
her now this cell only has when you're
lost in the darkness written on red on
the wall but not the full phrase like
it's written in yellow outside in the
area where Joel meets up with the
soldier it's just a way of showing how
the fireflies do not need the full
propaganda internally just bits and
pieces of it to remind them of their
mission but in different contexts now
this guy who operates the long distance
radio takes Joel's cigarettes which
remember was the five dollars extra that
Joel got from the soldier the radio
operator takes the cigarettes before he
tells Joels that he just heard nothing
from Tommy which kind of sucks Joel just
had to pay for bad news it's any answer
at all that cost the payment so Joel
drunkenly plots a Westward trip to find
Tommy and we see the watch that Sarah
repaired its face broken in two spots
now when Jess joins him in bed she rolls
him away from her so that he won't see
her facial wounds right away and get
worked up when he's super drunk and high
like throughout the morning he doesn't
even notice until he raises his head to
see her face the next morning during
breakfast now I might be wrong but that
woman they even passed in the wheelchair
might be the same pregnant woman who
radioed her parent earlier that they
were about to be a grandparent it's hard
to tell if the woman in the wheelchair
has her baby bum still I don't really
know what happened I just hope that
pregnant woman ended up being okay
Marlene gives Ellie this knife that
Ellie from here forward is extremely
attached to and Marlene reveals that she
knows her name is not Veronica and that
she was actually the one who put Ellie
in the federal military school Marlena
also brings up someone named Riley
there's a lot more to all this that I
will bring up at the end in the spoilers
section Joel and Tess are scared when
they find a recent infected victim you
think he came down after he was infected
maybe down here is where he was infected
now beyond the yuck of the quarter steps
outgrowth the fact that this person was
pinned against a wall I think is what is
most unnerving about this it's as if he
was on the ground when he died and then
the fungus lifted his corpse up as it
grew to find other victims Joel and test
find Robert and his guys already dead
and Marlene and her crew already wounded
it's really interesting that we don't
see this go down we come upon it after
just like we didn't really see any
initial conflict between Robert's crew
and Tess we didn't see those trespassers
actually get hanged think about it this
is HBO think it is violent as they want
but in the second half of this episode
they particularly withhold the violence
the violence in the QC in the second
half of this episode is rarely ever
shown happening it's more quiet it's
hinted at crime scene stumbled upon
after the fact not explicitly shown I'm
gonna explain why in a bit Ellie finds
Joel's local radio in his book of
billboard number one hits with this code
sheet for communications from Bill and
Frank 60s songs meaning nothing new 70s
songs meaning new stock is in and 80
songs at least able to do this later
using wham's wake me up to trick Joel
meaning trouble out there and this is
after Joel went in and out of sleep too
the sounds of Sarah's dying breaths
before when he slept when he was drunk
and loaded he heard his brother Tommy
shouting his name which is probably a
memory from their past fight so Joel and
Tess and Ellie head out past the wall
where they are stopped by that druggy
soldier from before who tests Ellie to
learn that she is positive so Ellie
stabs him with a knife and Joel flashing
back to the parallel moment when he
faced a soldier who killed his daughter
finally lets his rage boil over and he
snaps this is what Marlene referred to
by what they're capable of and why this
episode held off showing as Joel being
violent in this modern era until this
moment despite the early section of the
game here showing Joel and his disposing
of and killing a ton of guys instead we
just get this shocking and singular
punctuated moment of violence from our
hero that feels especially earned
grounded in the most devastating loss in
his life and directly motivating why
protecting Ellie is so important to him
and specifically what triggered the
memory for him was the light he was
blinded by this soldier's flashlight
just like he was blinded by the
headlights back in Texas because when
lost in the darkness you must look for
the light Craig Mason had an interesting
point about Ellie in this moment when
Ellie watches him beating a man to death
she is activated earlier in the episode
when Sarah sees him killing this old
woman who's infected who he has to kill
he killed her she cries Ellie likes it
and in the Companion podcast from HBO
Mason talked about this series being a
love story but how unconditional love
can be a very dangerous thing we will
continue to come back to the notion that
love conquers all and that's problematic
that we think of love as this solely
positive thing a beautiful thing and it
is but love especially the love that a
parent has for a child is Primal and it
can lead to the most intense fear and
the most intense fear can lead to the
most intense Behavior including violence
and if you scratch the surface of
tribalism racism xenophobia you will
find love love is not always good and
the music that plays over this ending
comes from Joel's local radio from Bill
and Frank Depeche Mode's never let me
down again an 80s track meaning danger
is ahead now Depeche Mode's song is
about taking a ride with your best
friend but that friend is really
addiction so this Bond forming between
Ellie and Joel not necessarily a healthy
thing amazing promises that we will hear
this song again this season at a key
moment the topple towers that they head
toward on their way to the State House
compared to the opening titles the road
of the fungus spreading toward its
towering stalks because the path before
all these characters is truly infected
now on to our spoiler corner for folks
more familiar with the games and comics
want to talk about these details or just
people don't really give a [ __ ] so
Marlene actually knew Ellie's Mother
Anna long before Ellie was wounded and
infected this switchblade used to belong
to Anna as we learned the prequel Comics
American Dreams and becomes Ellie's
primary weapon of the games that could
be why she's so pissed when Joel steps
on it and swipes it away he's
essentially stepping on her mother's
memory however in this show it seems
like Ellie did not know Marlene before
Ellie was captured by the fireflies it
seems like her mother's relationship
with Marlene is a full mystery to her
now Riley was Ellie's teenage partner
from the Left Behind DLC that was
initially referenced in The Last of Us
game this is the girl she snuck out with
and hung out with at the mall which is
where they were both infected but Ellie
survived Riley will appear later in the
season played by storm Reed there's
actually a shot in the trailer of them
taking a photo together I'm so excited
for this show I will be breaking down
the Easter eggs every Monday following
our after shows coming out on Sunday
nights a reminder to subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
launching February 17th with deeper
investigations from me every week you
can follow it on all socials at Deep
dive NR you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for breakdowns and theories of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]